hey guys it's Justine and inside of this
box is Timmy this is a personal robot
that I saw at CES this year this is one
of the world's first personal robots
with autonomous mobility and navigation
with Amazon Alexa built in this is super
exciting because we had so much fun
checking this out at CES and I'm kind of
in shock right now that it is in my
living room so we're gonna unbox temmie
and we're gonna test it out okay Tammy I
hope you're ready for fun I mean this is
life-changing this is like unboxing a
friend
[Music]
teni is inside Timmy
mommy's here oh no no oh
Maddy no I'm mommy come here with this I
know I'm your mommy to me this is inside
of here as a robot it's a personal robot
so it's gonna be using AI and it has 16
different cameras at different sensors
so that it will notice pure arounds it
won't run into you I think this is it
temmie is here you go this is one of my
favorite thing this is the little tray
it also doubles as a wireless charger so
I think that 10 me is going to follow me
around the house charging my phone and
it's Qi wireless charging so like
anything that is a chi wireless
compatible temmie will be able to charge
it for you
so this is Timmy's little charging base
which is great because Timmy just goes
home on its own to charge itself
whenever you're not using it okay
it looks good let's try that daddy's
gonna be absolutely terrified by Tammy I
know it to meet your eyes let me let me
help you hello hello hello 10 me so
Tammy has a 10 inch full HD screen and
it is saying hello to me place the home
base level on a surface flat against the
wall plug it into a power a place Tammy
on the home base okay let's go to your
home
hey there you new robot owner this is 10
the world's first truly interactive
assistant you can ask Tammy to follow
you around or you can send any to any of
your favorite locations and you'll go
there all by himself
these are we avoiding any obstacle
Debbie stacked full of goodies
like high-definition speakers or
enjoying music it sounds really good
wireless charging tree yes the wireless
charging tree I have that you're all set
let's start hey Tammy
what are you doing we are having a
pleasant human to robot conversation I
agree let's see if Tommy can play me
some music Hemi is now following me
around and Tammy also only has 10%
battery so Tammy go home this is a real
test
10% Timmy so I definitely gave to me a
struggle because there is a ridge where
I placed the home base that was a cool
pool trick that I played on you Tammy
I'm so sorry I'm gonna have to do why
oh it worked I even gave Tammy a
challenge and Tennie prevailed so I
guess I'll let Tammy completely charge
and then we'll see what else I can do
Tammy is all charged this is day two I
let it charge yesterday so that it would
get a nice full charge today so let's uh
let's follow me hi oh boy it's
calculating right now so there's a
little button up here so as soon as you
press it it automatically activates
follow mode
hey Tammy set this location as couch
number one okay saving location I
successfully save the couch location hey
Timmy set location as living room I
successfully saved a living room
location hey Timmy set location steps I
successfully saved the steps location so
there's two different ways you can set
different locations you can say over
Billy or you can just press this little
button right here which I'll show you
guys you can press right here and set as
new location so we're gonna set this as
kitchen I successfully saved the kitchen
location so I with your location set you
can see a kitchen steps living room
couch so I can't even tell Tammy to go
to one of these or I can just press
where I want it to go so let's go to the
couch it's going to the couch it's going
to the couch
okay that's pretty cool go to the
kitchen
[Music]
boy I sure could use a banana as a snack
hey Timmy go to entrance oh my gosh
bring me my banana
[Music]
hey Tommy take a video okay get ready
Timmy just brought me this banana I
can't believe it everything is awesome
Wow one of the cool things though is you
can actually call him - Timmy so say I'm
out of town or I'm somewhere else I
could call into Timmy and have it
navigate around my house in some of the
preset locations so let's try that okay
I'm gonna go upstairs I'm gonna call it
a Timmy and tell Tommy to go places oh
my gosh
tap a point of interest to put it in the
center okay I'm gonna tap on Tyler oh my
goodness this isn't quite you could also
do free driving I can drive this thing
around my house I'm in a bit of the same
location okay I'm gonna go to the living
room this is incredible I can go to any
look I'm gonna go back to go to Tyler
over there here we go this is so cool
okay
I am definitely sold like free this is
amazing but I can walk around my house
and I'm not even there I could be around
the world this was by far just such a
surreal experience I can't believe this
I could have been calling in from around
the world and controlling my robot at my
home I wasn't even here I could have had
a make sure that I unplugged something
maybe I wanted to make sure that I the
couch was still here so you could just
know just in case
so this is this is Timmy this is a new
friendly fun addition to my home this is
really cool because the future is gonna
be so incredible I mean the future is
actually here and this is something that
I feel like I just would have dreamed up
whenever the child to have my own
personal robot following me around it's
also really great because this is an
open SDK so developers are able to build
on top of this so basically any ideas
that you could potentially have they can
build it anyway I'm gonna head
me back to his home base and get charged
up my phone give me the man
oh my should take it a selfie with Timmy
Timmy look so cute
okay got my selfie see you guys later
[Music]